slaves produces surplus which the master
gets
serfs produces surplus which the lord
gets
employees produce a surplus which the
employer gets
it's very simple
these are
exploitative class structures because
one class produces a surplus
appropriated
distributed by another group of people
not the ones who produced it which
creates hostility enmity envy anger
resentment and all of the problems you
can lump under the heading
class
struggle
the following is a conversation with
richard wolff
one of the top marxist economists and
philosophers in the world
this is a heavy topic
in general and for me personally given
my family history in the soviet union in
russia and in ukraine
today the words marxism socialism and
communism are used to attack and to
divide
much more than to understand and to
learn
with this podcast i seek the latter
i believe we need to study the ideas of
karl marx as well as their various
implementations throughout the 20th and
the 21st centuries
and in general we need to both steal man
and to consider seriously the ideas we
demonize
and to challenge the ideas we
dogmatically accept is true
even when doing so is unpleasant and at
times dangerous
this is the lex friedman podcast to
support it please check out our sponsors
in the description and now dear friends
here's richard
wolff
let's start with the basic question but
maybe not so basic after all what is
marxism what are the defining
characteristics of uh marxism as an
economic and political theory and
ideology
well the simplest way to begin a
definition would be to say it's the
tradition
that takes its
founding inspiration from the works of
karl marx
but because
these ideas that he put forward
spread as fast as they did and as
globally as they did
literally it's 140
years since marx died
and in that time his ideas
have become
major
types of thinking in every country on
the earth
um if you know much about the great
ideas of human history
um
that's an extraordinary
spread in an extraordinarily short
period of historical time
and what that has meant that speed of
spread and that geographic diversity
is that the marxian ideas interacted
with
very different cultural histories
religious histories
and economic conditions
so the end result was that the ideas
were interpreted differently in
different places at different times
and therefore marxism
as a kind of first flush definition
is the totality of all of these very
different ways of coming to terms
with it
for the first
roughly 40 50 years
marxism was a tradition of thinking
critically about capitalism
marx himself that's all he really did he
never wrote a book about communism he
never wrote a book really about
socialism either
his comments were occasional fragmentary
dispersed what he was really interested
in was a critical analysis of capitalism
and that's what marxism was more or less
in its first 40 or 50 years
um
the only
qualification of what i just said
was something that happened in paris for
a few weeks
uh in 1871
there was a collapse of the french
government
uh
consequent upon losing a war to
bismarck's germany
and then the result was something called
the paris commune the working class of
paris rose up
basically took over the function of
running
the parisian economy and the parisian
society
and marx's people people influenced by
marx
were very active uh in that commune in
the leadership of the commune and marx
wasn't that far away he was in london
these things were happening in paris you
know that's
an easy transport even then
and for a short time
very short
marxism had a different
quality
in addition to being a critique of
capitalism it became
a theory of how to organize society
differently
before that had only been implicit now
it became explicit what is the
leadership of the paris commune going to
do
and why and in what order in other words
governing organizing a society but since
it only lasted a few weeks
the french army regrouped uh and under
the leadership of people who were very
opposed to marx
they
marched back into paris took over killed
a large number of the
of the communards as they were called
and deported them to islands in the
pacific that the that were part of the
french empire at the time
the really big change happens in russia
in 1917. now you have
a group of marxists led in trotsky all
the rest
who
are in this bizarre
position
to seize a moment once again a war like
in france
uh disorganizes the government
throws the government into a very bad
reputation because it is the government
that loses world war one has to withdraw
as you know uh breslatovsk and all of
that and the government collapses and
the army revolts
and in that situation a very small
political party
russian social democratic workers party
um
splits under the pressures of all of
this
into the bolshevik and menshevik
divisions lenin trotsky and the others
are in the bolshevik division and to
make a long story short he's in exile
his position lenin's position
makes him gets him deported because he
says russian workers should not be
killing
german workers i mean this is a war of
capitalists who are dividing the world
up into colonies and russian working
people have no
should not kill and should not die for
such a thing
as you can expect
they arrest him and they throw him out
interestingly in the united states the
the comparable leader at that time of
the socialist party here
as you know there was no communist party
at this point that comes later
um the head of the socialist party a
very important american figure
named eugene victor debs
makes exactly the same argument to the
the americans should not fight in the
war
uh he's in the pa he has nothing to do
with london i don't even know if they
knew of each other but uh he does it on
his own he gets arrested and put in jail
here in the united states by the way he
runs for president from jail and does
very well really very well remarkable
um and he's the inspiration for bernie
sanders if you if you see the link
um although he had much more courage
politically than bernie has that's
really interesting i'd love to return to
that link maybe later yes
history rhymes yes the complicated story
anyway the importance in terms of
marxism is that now
this seizure of power
by a group of marxists
that is a group of people inspired by
marx developing what you might call a
russian
even though there were differences among
the russians too but a russian
interpretation
this now
has to be transformed from a critique of
capitalism
into a plan at least what are you going
to do
in the soviet union
and a lot of this was then trial and
error
marx never laid any of this out
probably wouldn't have been all that
relevant if he had because it was 50
years earlier in another country etc
so what begins to happen and you can see
how this happens then more later in
china and cuba and vietnam and korea and
so on
is that you have
kind of a bifurcation
much of marxism remains
chiefly the critique of capitalism
but another part of it
becomes
a set and they differ from one to the
other a set of notions
of what an alternative
post-capitalist society ought to look
like how it ought to work
and there's lots of disagreement about
it
lots of confusion
um and i would say that that's still
where it is that you have a tradition
now
that has these two major wings critique
of capitalism notion of the alternative
and then a variety of each of those and
that would be the framework in which i
would answer that's what marxism is
about
its basic idea if you had to have one
is that human society
can do better than capitalism and it
ought to try
and then we can start to talk about
what we mean by capitalism fine
so we'll look at the critique of
capitalism on one side but maybe
stepping back what do you think marx
would say if he just looked at the
different implementations of the ideas
of marxism throughout the 20th century
where his ideas that were implicit were
made explicit
would uh would he shake his head would
he enjoy some of the parts of the
implementations like what how do you
think he would analyze it well he had a
great sense of humor i don't know if he
had a chance to take a look at his
writing but
he had an extraordinary sense of humor
so my guess is he would deploy his humor
in answering this question too
he would say some of them are inspiring
some of the interpretations of his work
and he's very pleased with those others
are horrifying and he wishes somehow he
could erase the connection between those
things and the lineage they claim
from him which he would
uh there's a german word i don't know if
he's lying if you speak the other
languages there's a wonderful german
word called fatsita
and it's stronger than the word refuse
it's if if you want to refuse something
but with real strong emphasis
is a german way of saying i i don't want
anything to do with that
and he would talk then you know in
philosophical terms because remember he
was a student of philosophy he wrote his
doctoral thesis on ancient greek
philosophy and all the rest he would wax
philosophical and say
you know that the ideas you put out are
a little bit like having a child
you have a lot of influence but the
child is his own or her own person and
will find his or her own way and these
ideas once they're out there
go their own way and as you said there's
a particular way that this idea spread
the speed at which it spread throughout
the world made it even less
able to be sort of stabilized right and
connected back to the origins of where
the idea came from
the only people who ever really tried
that
were the russians after the revolution
because they occupied a position for a
while not very long
but they occupied a position for a while
in which
i mean it was exalted right there had
been all these people criticizing
capitalism for a long time even the
marxists ever since mid-century
and these were the first guys
who pulled it off
they made it and so there was a kind of
presumption around the world their
interpretation must be kind of the right
one
because look
they they did it and so for a while
they could enunciate their
interpretation
and it came to be widely
grasped as something which by the way
gets called in the literature
official marxism the very idea that you
would put that adjective in front of
marxism or soviet marxism or russian
there were these words that
where the adjective was meant to somehow
say
kind of this is the canon
you can depart from it but this is the
canon before the russian revolution
there was no such thing
and
by the
1960s it was already desperate it was
gone but for a short time um 30 40 years
it was a kind of
and the irony is
particularly here in the united states
where the taboo against marxism kicks in
right after world war ii
is so total in this country
that
i for example through most of my adult
life
have had to spend a ridiculous amount of
my time simply explaining to american
audiences
that the marxism they take as canonical
is that old soviet marxism which wasn't
the canon before 1917 and hasn't been
since at least the 1960s
but they don't know
it's not that they're stupid and it's
not that they're ignorant it's that well
ignorance maybe but i mean it's not a
mental problem it's the taboo shut it
down and so all of the reopening
that in a way recaptures what went
before
and develops it in new direction they
just don't know
nevertheless it's a serious
attempt at making the implicit ideas
explicit the
the russians
the the soviets at the beginning of the
20th century made a serious attempt at
saying okay beyond the critique of
capitalism how do we actually build a
system like this and so in that sense
not at a high level but at a detailed
level it's interesting to look at those
particular
schools maybe right because for example
let me just take your point one step
further you really cannot understand the
cuban revolution the chinese revolution
uh vietnamese and the others because
each of them
is a kind of
response let's call it to the way the
soviets did it
are you going to do it that way well yes
and no is the answer this we will do
that way but that we're not going to do
and the differences are huge
but you could find a thread i can do
that for you if you want in which all of
them are in a way
reacting
to the originals yes
very much so like maybe most of rock
music is reacting to the beatles and the
stones there's something like that
can you speak to the unique elements of
the various schools of that soviet
marxism so we got leninism
trotskyism stalinism maybe even let's
expand out to uh maoism so
um maybe i could speak to sort of
leninism
uh and then please tell me if i'm saying
dumb things
there's a
i think for lenin
there was an idea that there could be a
small
sort of vanguard party like a small
controlling entity that's like wise and
is able to do the central planning
decisions
then for um
stalinism one interesting so stalin's
implementation of all of this one
interesting characteristic is to
move away from the international aspect
of the ideal marxism to uh make it all
about nation nationalism the strength of
nation
and then um so maoism is
it's it's different in that it's focused
on agriculture and rural
and then trotskyism i don't know
except that it's anti-stalin
i mean i don't even know if there's
unique sort of philosophical elements
there anyway can you maybe from those or
something else speak to different unique
elements that are interesting to think
about about implementation of marxism in
the real world probably the best way to
get in there into this
is to describe something that happened
in
marxism that then shapes the answer to
your question
in the early days of marx's writings
yeah and you know he his life spans the
19th centuries born in 1818 dies in 1883
so literally he lives the 19th century
and
you might i mean to make things simple
you might look at the first half of the
first two-thirds of his life
as overwhelmingly
gathering together
the precursors to his own work marx was
unusually
scholarly in the sense that partly
because he didn't work a regular job and
partly because he was an exile in london
most of his adult life
he worked in the library i mean he had a
lot of time he got subsidized a little
bit by angles whose family were
manufacturers
and
you might say the first half to
two-thirds of his life are about
the critique of capitalism
and that was what
in a broad sense the audience for his
work
western europe more or less
was interested in that's what they
wanted
and he gave that to them he wasn't the
only one but he was very very effective
at it
um
by the last third of his life
he and the other
producers
of a
anti-capitalist movement people like the
chartists in england that's a whole
nother movement
um
the
anarchists of various kinds like prudent
in france or krapotkin or bakunin and
russia and so on
you put all these together and there was
a shift
in what the audience
let's call it a mixture of
militant working-class people on the one
hand
and critical or radical intelligence
here on the other
they now wanted a different question
they were persuaded by the analysis they
were agreeable that capitalism
was a phase they would like to do better
than
and the question became how do we do
this
not anymore should we why should we
could we maybe fix capitalism no they
had gotten to the point the system has
to be fundamentally changed
but they got they didn't go yet you
might imagine they didn't go and say
well what will that new system looks
like
they didn't go that way what they did
was ask the question
how
could we get beyond capitalism it seems
so powerful it seems to have captured
people's minds people's daily lives and
so on um and the
focus of the conversation became this
was already by the last third of the
19th century
the question of
the agency the mechanism whereby we
would get beyond and again make a long
story short
the conversation focused
on seizing the government
see before that it wasn't that the
government was not a major interest if
you read marx's capital the great work
of his maturity three volumes there's
almost nothing in the state i mean he
mentions it but
he's interested in the details of how
capitalism works
factory by factory store by store office
what's the structure the government's
secondary for him but there's also
humans within that capitalist system of
there's the working class right
that's what he's struggle that's what
he's he's interested in each in the
world think of it almost mechanically
like the workplace in the workplace
there some people who do this and other
people who do that and they accept this
division of authority and they accept
this division of what's going on here
particularly because he believed that
the core economic
objective of capitalism was to maximize
something called profit which his
analysis located right there in the
workings of the enterprise and not in
the government was not the the key
factor here and he was looking at ideas
of value
yes how much is the
how much value does the labor of the
individual
workers provide and that means
how do we reward the workers in an
ethical way and so those are the
questions of uh right well
we'll get it yeah okay but the
government is not part of that picture
okay so it's very significant that
towards the end of the 19th century marx
is still alive when this begins but it
really gets going after he dies
is this debate among marxists
about the role of the state
they all agreed nearly all of them agree
that you have to get the same the
working class has to get the state
because they see the state as the
ultimate guarantor of capitalism when
things get really out of hand the
capitalist calls the police or he calls
the army or both of them and so the
government is in a sense this key
institution
captured in marx's lang marxist language
by the bourgeoisie by the by the other
side the capitalists
and yet vulnerable because of suffrage
if suffrage is universal or nearly so
if everybody gets a vote which in a way
capitalism brings to bear part of its
rejection of feudalism in the french
american revolution is to create a place
where elected represented so that the
government being
subject to suffrage
creates the notion aha
here's how we're gonna we have to seize
the state
and then the the
that gets agreed upon but there's a big
split as to how to do it
one side says
you go with the election you you you
mobilize the voter
that gets to be called reformism within
marxism and the other side
is revolution
don't do that this system if i may quote
bernie again is rigged
uh you can't get there
they've long ago learned how to
manipulate uh parliaments they buy the
politicians and all that
and therefore revolution is going to be
the way to do it revolution
gets a very big boost because the
russians they did it that way they
didn't do i mean they fought in the
douma in the in the parliament but
they didn't and that this focus on the
state i would argue
goes way beyond what the debaters at the
time
and if you're interested in the great
names
there was a great theorist of the
the role of the state in a reformist
strategy to get power uh in germany
named edward bernstein very important
his opponents in germany
were karl kautzke
and rosa luxemburg the two other huge
figures in marxism at the time and
they wrote the articles that everybody
reads but it was a much broader
uh debate and by the way that debate
still goes on
reformism versus revolution
and in in terms not all that different i
mean it's adjusted to history but in
terms of different can you comment uh on
where you
lean in terms of
the mechanism of progress
reformation versus i'd rather tell you
the historical sure
over and over and over again in most
cases
the reformists have always won
because revolution is frightening is
scary is dangerous
um
and so most of the time when you get to
the point where it's even a relevant
discussion not an abstract thing for
conferences but a real
strategic issue
the reformists have won i mean and
i'll give you an example from the united
states in the great depression of the
1930s
you had an extraordinary
shift to the left in the united states
the greatest shift to the left in the
country's history before or since
nothing like it
suddenly
you created a vast
left wing composed of the labor movement
which went crazy in the 19th hour we
organized more people into unions in the
1930s than at any time before or anytime
since it is the explosion and at the
same time the explosion of two socialist
parties and the communist party that
became very powerful and they all worked
together creating
a very powerful leftist
presence in this country they debated in
a strategically real way
reform or revolution
the reformers were the union people by
and large and the the communists were
the revolutionaries by and large because
they were affiliated with the
communist international with russia and
all of that and in between you might say
that the two socialist parties one that
was trotskyist and inspiration and the
other one more
moderate western european kind of
socialism and they had this intense
debate
and they ended up the reformists won
that debate there was no revolution in
the 1930s here
but there was
a reform that achieved unspeakably great
successes
which is why it was as strong and
remains as strong as it does because it
achieved in in a few years in the 1930s
starting around 1932-3
social security in this country we had
never had that before it's the same one
we have now
unemployment insurance never existed
before that you have until today
minimum wage for the first time still
have that today
and a federal program of employment that
hired 15 million people
i mean these were unspeakable gifts if
you like to the working class so that's
the 30s and the 40s 30s very much in the
40s anymore but in the 30s and here's
the best part
it was paid for by taxes on corporations
and the rich
so what when people today say well you
can tax the government the joke is i
have to teach american history to
americans
uh because it has been erased from
consciousness we'll return to that but
first let's let's take a stroll back to
the beginning of the 20th century with
the russians with the russians so
their interpretation goes like this
everybody was right the state is crucial
we were right we were the
revolutionaries we seized the state here
in russia
now we have the state and socialism is
when the working class
captures this state either by reform a
revolution and then uses its power over
the state to make the transition from
capitalism to the better thing we're
going toward
and again make a long story short in the
interest of time
what happens which is not unusual in
human history
is that the means
becomes the end
in other words lenin who's crystal clear
before he does he doesn't live very long
he dies in 23 so he's only in power from
17 you say to 22 but that time he has
his brain trouble not in 1923 by the way
not at age 23 yeah yeah before listening
1923. yeah he's only there for four or
five years
uh he's very clear he even says and i've
done work on i've published so i know
this stuff
he says in a famous speech let's not
fool ourselves
we have captured the state
but we don't have socialism we have to
create that we have to move
towards that
um
with stalin you know lenin dies and
there's a fight between stalin and
trotsky trotsky loses the fight he's
exiled he goes to mexico stalin is now
alone in power and does all the things
he's famous or infamous for
um
and by the end of the 20s stalin
makes
a decision i mean not him it's not that
he makes it alone but
things have evolved in russia so that
they do the following they declare
that they are
socialism in other words
socialism becomes
when you capture the state
not when the state capture has enabled
you to do x y z other things no no the
state itself
once you have it
is socialism so when a socialist
captures the state that's socialism
exactly
and
that's exactly right and i feel like
that's definitionally confusing well it
shouldn't be because we get an example
yeah
if you go to many parts of the united
states today and you ask people
what's socialism
they'll tell you they look you right in
the face and they'll say the post office
and you you know when i first heard this
as a young man you know what
the post office
it took me a while to understand the
post office amtrak the tennessee
all the examples in the united states
where the government
runs something
this is
socialism
see capitalism is if the government
doesn't run it if a private individual
who's not a government official runs it
well then it's capitalism if the
government takes it then it's socialist
so what is wrong with that
reasoning so the idea i think
there's nothing wrong with it's a way of
looking at the world it's just got
nothing to do with marx well there's
marks there's marxism
let's try to pull this apart so
what role
uh
does central planning have
in marxism
so
marxism is concerned
with this class struggle
with respecting the working class right
what is the connection
between
that struggle and central planning that
is often
central planning is often associated
with marxism right so a centralized
power doing russia did that allocation
so that's a that's that has to do with a
very specific set of implementations
initiated by the soviet union has
nothing to do with marxism how else can
you do i don't think you can find yes
anywhere in marx's writing
anything about central planning or any
other kind of planning again
fundamentally then uh marx
marx's work it has to do
with um
with factories with workers with with
the bourgeoisie with the
and and the uh the the exploitation of
the working class
but you still have to take that leap
what is beyond capitalism right so maybe
we should turn to that expl yes on that
okay yes what okay we've already looked
historically at several attempts right
to go beyond capitalism
how else can we go beyond capital right
let me push it a little further
they didn't succeed in my judgment as a
marxist
and i'm now going to tell you why they
didn't succeed because they didn't
understand as well as they could have or
should have
what marxist was trying to do
i think i would have been like them if i
had lived at their time under their
circumstances this is not a critique of
them
but it's a different way of
understanding what's going on all right
so
give you an example
most of my adult life i have taught
marxian economics
i'm a professor of economics i've been
that all my life
i'm a graduate of american universities
as it happens i'm a graduate of what in
this country passes for its best
universities
with another conversation you and i can
have
so i went to harvard then i went to
stanford and i finished at yale i'm like
a poster boy for elite education
they tried very hard by the way i had i
spent 10 years of my life in the ivy
league 20 semesters one after the other
no break
in those 20 semesters 19 of them never
mentioned a word about marxism
that is no critique of capitalism was
offered to me
ever with one except one professor in
stanford in the one semester i studied
with him he gave me plenty to read but
nobody else so
that's really interesting you you've
mentioned that in the past and that's
very true which makes you a very
interesting figure
to hold your ground
intellectually
through this idea space where just
people
don't really even talk about it um
perhaps we can discuss historically why
that is but nevertheless that's the case
so
moxy and economics did karl marx come up
in conversation
as a kind of
dismissal
the best example yeah he came up only as
an object of dismissal so give an
example
the major textbook in economics that i
was taught with and that be was for many
years the canonical book isn't quite
anymore
um
was a book authored by a professor of
economics at mit named paul samuelson
and people kind of you know a whole
generation or two were trained on his
textbook if you open the cover of his
textbook he has a tree
and you know and the tree is adam smith
and david ricardo at the at the root and
then the different branches of he's
trying to give you an idea as a student
of how the thing developed
and it's a tree and everybody on it is
the bourgeois
and then there's this one little
that goes off like this and sort of
starts heading back down that's karl
marx in other words
he had to have it complete because she's
not a complete faker but beyond that no
there was no
nothing in the book gives you two
paragraphs
of an approach
but that's cold war i mean that that's
really that's really neither here that
that's the craziness yeah that's the
cold war in this country my professors
were afraid anyway let me get to the
to the core of it what i think will help
marx was interested in the relationship
of people in the process of production
that he's interested in the factory the
officer store what goes on and by that
he means what are the relationships
among the people that come together in a
workplace
and
what he analyzes is that there is
something going on there
that
has not been adequately understood
and that has not been adequately
addressed as an object needing
transformation
what does he mean
the answer is
exploitation which he defines
mathematically in the following way
whenever in a society any society
you organize
people
adults not the children not the sick but
you know healthy adults
in the following way
a big block of them a clear majority
work that is they use their brains and
their muscles to transform nature a tree
into a chair a sheep into a woolen
sweater whatever
in in every human community marx argues
there are the people who do that work
but they always produce
more chairs more sweaters more
hamburgers than they themselves consume
whatever their standard of living
doesn't have to be low can be medium can
be high but they always produce more
than they themselves consume
that more by the way jer marx when he
writes this uses the german word mere
m-e-h-r which is the english equivalent
of more it's the more that more got
badly translated into the word surplus
shouldn't have been but it was by by the
way by german and english people doing
the translations what's the difference
between more and surplus is there a
nuanced yeah because surplus has a
notion of it's discretionary it's sort
of extra
he's not taking a he's not making a
judgment that it's a simple math
equation yes very simple one minus the
other yes x minus
this one
x is the total output y is the
consumption by the producer therefore x
minus y equals s the surplus exactly
exactly
now marx argues
the ques the minute you understand this
you will ask the following question
who gets the surplus
who gets this extra stuff
that is made but not consumed by those
who made it
and marx's answer is
therein lies one of the great shapers of
any society how is that organized for
example who gets it
what are they asked if anything to do
with it in re in exchange for getting it
what's their social role
for example here we go now if you get
this and you get the core of it anyway
um
and i don't charge much um
the workers themselves could get less
than lawyers right that's right
uh the workers themselves could get it
yes that's the closest marx comes to a
definition of communism
communism would would be
if the workers who produce the surplus
together
decide what to do with it
so this has to do not just with who gets
it but more importantly who gets to
decide who gets it well who gets it and
who get gets to decide what to do with
it right
because you can't decide it if you don't
have disposition over it so the a lot
just the logic of the word sequence
it's produced
it's marx uses the word appropriated in
other words whose property who who gets
to decide if you like what happens all
that property ever meant is who gets to
decide and who's excluded that's a clean
definition of communism first right
and that's the by the way it's not just
clean it's the only one so what's uh can
we just linger on the definition of
exploitation in
easy becomes very easy to exploitation
exists if and when
the surplus that's produced is taken and
distributed by people other than those
who produced it slaves produce a surplus
which the master gets
serfs produces surplus which the lord
gets
employees produce a surplus which the
employer gets
it's very simple
these are exploitative
class structures because one class
produces a surplus
appropriated
distributed by another group of people
not the ones who produced it which
creates hostility enmity envy anger
resentment and all of the problems you
can lump under the heading
class
struggle i use a metaphor simple
metaphorical story you have two children
let's assume and you take them to
central park a few blocks from here it's
a nice day and the children are playing
and in comes one of those men with an
ice cream truck comes by
ding-a-ling-a-ling-ling your children
see the ice cream daddy get me an ice
cream so you walk over you take some
money and you get two ice cream cones
and you give them to one of the children
the other one begins to scream and yell
and howl
obviously what's the issue
and you realize you've just made a
terrible mistake
so you order
the one you gave the two ice cream cones
to give one of those to your sister or
your brother or whatever it is
and that that's how you solve the
problem
until a psychologist comes along and
says
you know
you didn't fix it by what you just did
you should never have done that in the
first place
my response so you understand
all of the efforts to deal with
inequality in
economic political culture these are all
giving the ice cream cone back to the
kid you should you should never do this
in the first place the reallocation of
resources creates bitterness populous
look at arthur we've this country is
tearing itself apart now in a way that i
have never seen in my life and i've
lived here all my life and i've worked
here all my life
it's tearing itself apart and it's
tearing itself apart basically
over the redivision the redistribution
of wealth having so badly distributed in
the fir but that's all in marks and
notice as i explained to you
what is going on in this tension-filled
production scene in the office the
factory the store i don't have to say a
word about the government i'm not
interested in the government the
government's really of a very secondary
matter to this core question and here
comes the big point
if you make a revolution
and all you do is remove the private
exploiter
and substitute a government official
without changing the relationship
you know you can call yourself a marxist
all day long but you're not getting the
point of the marxism the point was not
who the exploiter is but the
exploitation per se you've got to change
the organization of the workplace so
there isn't a group that makes all the
decisions and gets the surplus
vis-a-vis another one that produces it
if you do that you will destroy the
whole project you will not only will you
not achieve what you set out to get but
you'll so
misunderstand it that you the germans
again have a phrase it's chief it goes
crooked it doesn't go right the project
gets off the rails because it can't
uh it can't understand either what its
objective should have been and therefore
it doesn't understand how and why it's
missing its objective it just knows that
this is not what it had hoped for i mean
there's a lot of fascinating questions
here so one one is
to what degree so there's human nature
to what degree
does communism
uh a lack of exploitation of the working
class naturally emerge if you leave two
people together in a room and come back
a year later if you leave five people
together in a room if you leave a
hundred people and a thousand people
it seems that humans form hierarchies
uh naturally so the the clever the
charismatic
uh the sexy the the muscular the
powerful what however you define that uh
starts
start you know becoming a leader and
start to
do
um maybe exploitation in a non-negative
sense a more generic sense
starts to
become an employer
not in a capitalist sense but just as a
human here you go do this and in
exchange i will give you this just
becomes the leadership role right uh so
the question is yes okay it would be
nice
the idea sort of of communism would be
nice to
um
theory but it doesn't work in practice
because of human nature because of human
nature that's thank you
so what what can we say about leveraging
human nature to achieve some of these
ends
there's so many ways of responding
in no particular order here here are
some of them
um the history of the human race
as best i can tell
is a history in which
a succession of
social forms forms of society
arise
and as they do
they
rule out some kinds of human behavior
on the grounds that they are socially
disruptive and unacceptable
the argument isn't really then
is there a need or an instinct is there
some human nature
that makes people want to do this
well whatever that is this has to be
repressed or else we don't have a
society
you know and freud helps us to
understand
that that repression is going on all the
time and it has consequences it's not a
finished project you repress it it's
gone it doesn't work like that
so for example
when you get a bunch of people together
at some point they may develop
animosities towards one another that
lead them to want the other person or
persons to disappear to be dead to be
gone
but we don't permit you to do that
we just don't
every economic system that has ever
existed
has included people who defend it
on the grounds that it is the only
system consistent with human nature and
that every effort to go beyond it has to
fail because it contradicts human nature
i can show you endless documents of
every tribal society i've ever studied
every anthropological community that has
ever been studied slavery wherever it's
existed i can show you endless documents
in which the defenders of those systems
not all of them of course but many
defenders used that argument to
naturalize a system is a way to hold on
to it to prevent it from going to
counter the argument that every system
is born every system evolves and then
every system dies
and therefore capitalism since it was
born and since it's been developing we
all know what the next stage of
capitalism is what can infer
you're is what you're saying the burden
is on the people who think it isn't okay
so it doesn't mean they're wrong but
what you're saying is if you look at
history
you're deeply suspicious of the argument
this is going against human nature
because we keep using that for basically
everything including toxic relationship
toxic systems absolutely destructive
systems
that said uh well let me just
ask a million different questions so so
one
what about the the argument that sort of
the employer
uh the capitalist takes on risk
so
the yeah versus the employee who's just
there doing the labor the the capitalist
is actually putting up a lot of risk
what's uh
uh are they not in sort of aggregating
this organization and taking this giant
effort hiring a lot of people
aren't they taking on risk that this is
going to be a giant failure so first of
all there's risk
almost in everything you undertake any
project that begins now and ends in the
future it takes a risk that between now
and that future something's going to
happen that makes it not work out
i mean i got into a cab before i came
here today in order to do this with you
yes i took a risk i could the cab could
have been in an accident the lightning
could have hit us uh a bear could have
eaten my left foot who the hell no
shouldn't i reward you for the risk you
took no hold it a second let's do this
step by step sure so everybody's taking
a risk i always found it wonderful you
talk about risk and then you imagine
it's only some of us who take a risk
let's go with the worker in the with the
capitalist
that worker
he moved his family from
michigan to pennsylvania to take that
job
he had he made a decision to have
children
they are teenagers they're now in school
at a time when their friendships are
crucial to their development you're
gonna yank them out of the school
because his job is gone he took an
enormous risk
to do that job every day
to forestall all the other things he
could have done he was taking a risk
that this job would be here tomorrow
next month next year
he bought a house which americans only
do with mortgages which means he's now
stuck he has to make a monthly payment
if you
make a mistake
you capitalist
he's the one who's gonna you're a
capital you've got a lot of money
otherwise you wouldn't be in that
position
you got you've got a cushion he doesn't
if you investigate you'll see that in
every business i've ever been and i've
been involved in a lot of them so you
think it's possible to actually measure
risk or is your basic argument is
there's risk involved in a in a lot of
both the working class and the
bourgeoisie the capitalists that's right
and the worker the worker would never
come and say
because she's been taught right
um
i want this payment a wage
for the work i do
and i want this page
this payment for the risk i take well
there's some level of communication like
that you you have acknowledgement of
dangerous jobs but that's probably built
into the salary all those kinds of
things you you unders but you're not
incorporating you don't have a full
spectrum of risk
you don't believe that this country is
now being
literally transformed from below by an
army of workers who work at amazon fast
food joints you know what their
complaint is
it's killing us
we get paid [ __ ]
and it's killing us there is no
relationship except in the minds of the
defenders of capitalism between the
ugliness the difficulty the danger of
labor on the one hand and the wage let
me give you just a couple of examples
this is my this my job this my life what
i do all right the median income
of a child care worker in the united
states right now as we speak
is 11 and 22 cents an hour median so 50
make less 50 mate more the median income
for car park attendant
is several dollars per hour higher than
that
what does the car park attendant do he
stares at your car
for many hours to make sure that nobody
comes and grabs it
maybe
he parks it and moves it around to get
it in and out
by any measure that i know of that makes
any rational sense being in charge of of
toddlers two three four year olds who
are at the key moment of mental
formation the first five years to do to
give that a lower salary than you give
the guy who watches your car
come on i know how to explain it
gender explained all kinds of issues ex
the the car park people are males and
the child care people are females and
that that in our culture is a very big
marker of what but the one who said only
the economics professor
nobody else
says this stuff because in economy i
don't know if you were familiar with our
profession but we have something which
we call
marginal product this is a this is a
fantasy
i i was a mathematician before i became
an economist i loved mathematics i i
specialized in mathematics so i know
mathematics pretty well
what economists do is silly he's
childish but they think it's mathematics
or furry sophisticated it isn't
but
think for a minute what it means
to suggest that you can identify
the marginal product
of a factor of production like a worker
in in the textbook when it's taught i've
taught this stuff
i hold my nose but i teach it then i
explain to students what i just taught
you is horse [ __ ] but i first i teach it
what is the marginal product if it might
be useful the notion is
if you take away one worker right now
from the pile what will be the
diminution
of the output that's the marginal
product of that worker measured by
the amount of the output that diminishes
the output of the raw product of the
product usually in real terms so
physical not not the value you could do
a value but it's really more the
physical you're having i mean i there is
a transformation thing that will i'd
love to talk to you about
about value it's so interesting
i'll be glad to talk to you about value
and price and all of that but i just
want to get to the
hegel who's marx's teacher has a famous
line
you can't step in this in the same river
twice
and the argument is you and the river
have changed
between the first and the second time so
it's a different you and it's a
different you can choose not to pay
attention to that just you can't claim
you're not doing that you can't claim
that you can actually do that because
you can't there is no way to do that so
the the meaning that you can't just
remove a worker and have a clean
mathematical calculation of the effect
that it has on the output right because
too many other things are going on too
many things are changing and you cannot
assume
much as you want to
that the outcome on the output side is
uniquely determined by the change you
made on the input side can't do that
even in the even in the average it's
it's not going to work out you can take
look mathematics is full of abstractions
you can abstract you can say as as we do
in economics ketter is parabus you know
everything else held constant
but you have to know what you just did
you held everything you know why you do
that because you can't do that in the
real world that's not possible you
better account for that otherwise you're
mistaking the abstraction
from the messy reality you abstracted
from to get the abstraction
as a quick tangent if we somehow went
through a thought experiment or an
actual experiment of removing every
single economist from the world would be
better off or worse off much better off
okay
economics and i'm one you know i'm
talking about myself
see economics we're going to ship ship
all the economies to mars
see how it works off but the serious
part of this is that
economics
you know it's really about capitalism
economics as a discipline is born with
capital there was no such thing
when i teach i teach courses at the
university for example called history of
economic thought
right and i begin the students with
aristotle and plato
and i say you know they talked about
really interesting things
but they never called it economics there
was no
it nev it made no sense to people to
abstract
something as central to daily life as
economics broadly defined it made no
sense that's a creation much much later
that's capitalism that did that created
the feeling so when i give them plato
and aristotle i have to give them
particular passages
by the way footnote because your
audience will like it plato and
aristotle talked about markets because
they lived at a time in ancient greece
when market relations were beginning to
intrude upon these societies
so they were both interested in this
phenomena that we're not just producing
goods and then distributing among those
we're doing it in a quid pro quo you
know i'll give you three oranges you
give me two shirts a market exchange
and both aristotle and plato
hated markets denounced them and for the
same reason
they destroy
social cohesion they destroy community
they make some people rich and other
people poor and they set us against each
other and it's terrible and here's what
that's they agreed on that here's what
they disagreed on
one of them
said okay there can be no markets
that was plato aristotle comes back and
says no no no no no too late for that
the disruption caused in society by
getting rid of this institution that has
crawled in amongst us would be too
devastating
so we can't do that but what we can do
is control it regulate it
get from the market what it does
reasonably well and prevent it from
doing the destructive things it does so
badly
so the the fundamentally the destructive
thing of a market is it's the engine of
capitalism so it creates exploitation of
the worker it facility i wouldn't say
that's to facilitate it facilitates it
and it is an institution that plato and
aristotle feel is a terrible danger to
community is there which by the way is a
way of thinking about it that exists
right now all over the world
look the medieval catholic church
had a doctrine the prohibition of usury
you know and this was
that god said
if there's a person who needs to borrow
from you
then that's a person in need
and the good christian thing to do
is to help him
to demand an interest payment rather
than to help your fellow man
is
god hates you for that that's a sin
jesus is crying all the way to wherever
it is he goes but would jesus be crying
when you try to scale that system so
that has to do with the
intimate human interaction
the idea of markets is you're able
uh to create a system that involves
thousands millions of humans and there'd
be some level of
safe
self-regulating
fairness
there might be but it's hard to imagine
that charging interest would be the way
to do that i wonder what so i guess
suppose suppose you were interested in
having
uh
suppose you took us your problem
we have a set of funds that can be
loaned out
people don't want to consume it they're
ready to lend it
okay
to whom should they lend it
what we could say in our society
we're going to run this the way
professors
in institutions like mit
work this
they write up a project
they send the project in to some
government office
where it is looked at against other
projects
and this office in the government
decides we're going to fund this one
and that one because they're more
needed in our society we we're in
greater need of solving this problem
than that problem and so we're going to
lend money to people working on this
problem more readily or more money than
we lend over here because we're going to
but instead what we do is who can pay
the highest interest rate
whoa what what what do you do it why why
what ethics would justify you do it it's
like a market in general something is in
shortage all markets are about how to
handle shortage that's one basic way to
understand it
and so if if the demand is greater than
the supply which is all the word
shortage
means has no other meaning if the demand
is greater than the supply okay now you
got a problem you can't satisfy
all the demanders
because you don't have enough supply
you have a shortage okay now how are you
gonna do it in a market you allow people
who have a lot of money to bid up the
price of whatever's short
and you that solves your problem because
as the price goes up the poor people
can't they drop out they can't buy the
thing at the exalted price so you've got
a way of distributing the shortage it
goes to the people with the most money
at this point most human beings
confronted with this explanation of a
market
would turn against it because it
contradicts their christian judaic
islamic all of them would say
what you know what that means it means
that a rich person can get the scarce
milk and give it to their cat
while the poor food person has no milk
for their five children
there it is do you want a market why the
fundamental thing that seems unfair
there's the resulting inequality
now or death
or death well that's the ultimate
inequality yes it is
what about
and we're going to jump around from the
philosophical from the economics to the
sort of uh
debate type of thing
what about sort of the lifting ties
raise all boats
meaning
if we look at the 20th century right
a lot of people maybe disagree with this
but they attribute a lot of the
innovation and the
average improvement in the quality of
life
uh to capitalism right to inventions and
innovation to engineering
and science developments
that resulted from competition and all
those kinds of forces
um so not looking at the individual
unfairness of
exploitation as it's
specifically defined but just observing
historically looking at 20th century we
came up with a lot of cool stuff that
seemed to have made life easier
uh and better
on average
what do you say to that
i have several responses to that um but
i do disagree pretty far fundamentally
with what's going on there but but let
me give you the arguments so you that
you can hear them and then you can
evaluate them as can anybody who's
listening or watching
um
marx was a student of hegel and one of
hegel's central arguments was that
everything that exists
exists quote in the contradiction
in simple english
there's a good and bad side if you like
to everything
and you won't understand it unless you
accept that proposition and start
looking
for the good things that are the other
side of the bad ones and the bad things
that are the other side of the goodwill
etc
so they're dialectic yes exactly and
marx very attentive to that
explicitly agrees with this on many
occasions and applies it of course to
the central object of his research
capitalism
so this is not a simple-minded fellow
who's telling you all the bad things
about capitalism as if there were
nothing that this system achieved or
accomplished and one of the things he
celebrates a lot
is
the technological dynamism of the system
uh which marx takes to be
profound because you know he lived at
the time when major breakthroughs in in
textile technology and mining uh and
chemistry and so on were achieved
um
but as to the notion that that
capitalism is therefore responsible
for the improvement in
in the quality or the standard of living
of the mass of people mark stein comes
back and says oh wait wait a minute here
number one
capitalism as a system
has been mostly represented by
capitalists which makes a certain sense
and those capitalists with very few
exceptions some but very few
have fought against every effort to
improve the lives of the mass of people
the goal of a capitalist is to minimize
labor costs what that means is replace a
worker with a machine
move the production from expensive u.s
to cheap china
bring in desperate immigrants from other
parts of the world because they will
work for less money than the folks that
you have here at home
uh every measure to help the standard of
living of american workers had to be
fought for
for decades over the opposition of
capitalists from the beginning
to right now
the reason we have a minimum wage which
was past 19 middle of the 1930s
when it was proposed it was blocked by
capitalists they got together they don't
and today
just a factoid for you
the last time the minimum wage was
raised in the united states federal
minimum wage was in 2009
when it was set at the lofty sum of
seven dollars and 25 cents an hour
which you cannot live on
over the last 12 years or so whatever it
is not 11 12 13 years
since then
we have had an increase in the price
level in this country every year
and in the last year eight and a half
percent
during that time that the prices went up
the minimum wage was never raised
what
this is a time of stock market boom of
growing inequality this is a
you know
the nerve of the defender of
capitalists who wants now to get credit
for the improvement in the standard of
life of the workers that was fought by
every generation
you know it takes your breath away it's
an argument
whoa but i take my hat off if i had one
because that is one of the only ways to
justify this system
long ago let me get it the heart of it
long ago capitalism
could have
overcome hunger
could have overcome disease
could have i mean way beyond what we
have now
but it didn't yeah and that's the worst
moral condemnation imaginable how do you
justify
that when you could you didn't
look i let me get at it another way
because this may it may interest you
anyway
the issue is not that capitalism isn't
technologically dynamic it is and along
the way it has developed things that
have helped people's lives get better no
question
but the notion that the
the mass enjoyment of a rising standard
of living is somehow built into
capitalism
is factually nuts
and
is such an
outrageous and i can give you because
you do math you'll understand it think
of it this way
imagine a production process in which
you have um
a hundred dollars that the capitalist
has to lay out for tools equipment and
raw materials
and a hundred dollars that he has to lay
out for workers hire the workers and he
puts them all together and he has an
output
and let's say
the output is a hundred units of
something in one of the prices
and that's his revenue
and when he when he
takes his product and sells it and gets
the revenue
let's say the revenue is it doesn't
really matter it's
a hundred and twenty for lack of a
better word and he take 220 sorry and he
takes 100 of it and replaces the tools
equipment and raw materials he used up
another hundred to hire the workers for
the next shift and the other 20 is his
profit and he puts that aside
now along comes a technological
breakthrough
a machine a new machine
and the new machine is so effective
you can get the same out the same number
of units of output with half the workers
so you don't need to spend 100 on
workers you only need to spend 50.
you can do it with half the workers
and so the capitalist goes to the
workers by the way this happens every
day and he says to half of them you're
fired
don't come back monday morning i don't
need you it's nothing personal i just i
got a machine
why does he do that because the 50 he
now no longer has to spend on labor
because don't need half of them
he keeps everything else is the same the
machine everything else is this just to
make the math easy so he he keeps as his
own profit the 50 that before he paid
for those workers yeah right because
when he sells it for 220
that 50 don't have to give to the next
year because he has a new machine
so that's what he does
the technology leads
he's happy
he's become more profitable he's got an
extra 50 which is why he buys the
machine
the workers
are screwed
half of them just lost their job have to
go home to their husband and wife tell
them i don't have a job anymore i didn't
do anything wrong the guy was nice
enough to say there was nothing wrong
with me but he doesn't need him you know
so i'm i'm completely screwed here i
don't know what i'm going to do about
the debts we have the house on mortgage
my children's education or whatever else
he's got going for himself
right now now the point
there was of course an alternative path
the alternative path would have been to
keep all the workers
pay them exactly the same that you did
before
for half a day's work
you would have got the same output
same revenue
same profit as before
but the gain of the technology
would have been a half a day of freedom
every day of the lives of these workers
the majority of workers would have been
really
helped
by this technology
but instead they were screwed
so that one guy the employer could make
a big bundle of more money
you want to support a system like this
well uh to go back to hegel yes the good
and the bad yes
so
you just listed the bad and you also
first listed the good the technological
innovation of this kind of system
the question is the alternative
uh whatever
as we try to sneak up to ideas of what
the alternative might look like right
what are the good and the bad of the
alternative so you just kind of as a
opposite in the contra by contrast
showed that well a nice alternative is
you work less
get paid the same you have more leisure
time right opportunity to to pursue
other
interests other interests the creative
interests family right flourish as a
human being uh basically uh strengthen
and uh embolden the basic humanity
that's under all of us yes but then
what cost does that have
on the um
the deadline
fueled
competition-fueled machine
of technological innovation that is the
positive side of capitalism slows it
down it slows it down and the question
is
which is more important for the
flourishing of humanity i love i agree
with that and i'd love there to be
a democratic mechanism so let's let's
discuss it let's debate it and then
let's uh decide what mixture because
it's not either or the math problem i
gave you is either or we could mix it
you could have
a third less of a working day instead of
a half less and then the other part
would be extra profit for our employer
etc so let's have a democratic
discussion
of what is the mix between the positive
and we have no such thing all of this is
decided by one side in this debate which
not only
we know what they do they always choose
the one that maximizes their profit
because that's what they were told to do
in business school where i've taught
right um so we
not only is it an undemocratic decision
but it's lopsided to boot so we don't
have the opportunity but i would love
for us
to be good hegelian marxists and say
let's take a look at the plus and the
minus and make the best decision that we
can we'll make mistakes but we'll all
make them together it won't be one of us
making a dictatorial decision
you know marx developed the notion of
the dictatorship of the proletariat not
as a notion of how government
is not i'm sorry not marx lenin did that
not as a notion of how a government
works but as a notion of what the
practical reality is
the dictatorship in these key decisions
is not made by some sitting council it's
made by each little capitalist in his
her relationships with the workers in
the workplace which is why marx focused
his analysis on that point
and by the way i can sketch for you
right now so it doesn't lurk in the
background what the alternative is let's
go there okay it goes right back to what
i said earlier
the workers themselves the collection of
employees
together
appropriate their own surplus and decide
democratically what to do with it which
includes the decision of whether or not
to buy a machine
and whether or not
to use the machine and the savings it
might allow
to be
handled by more leisure for themselves
or as a fund
for new developments
in technology or new products or
whatever
they want
and you know this this is an old idea in
human marx loved that toward the end of
his life he
he started reading extensively in
anthropology and one of the reasons he
did that toward the end of his life was
because he kept discovering
that in this society in that including
here in the united states
that there were examples
of people who organized their production
in precisely this way
as a collective
democratic
community
in which everybody had an equal voice so
we all together decide democratically
what to produce how to produce where to
produce and what to do with the output
we all help to produce so let's do it in
you know in this country
where
democracy
is a
value nearly everybody subscribes to
think about it this way the stunning
contradiction
that there is a place in our society
where democracy has never been allowed
to enter
the workplace
in the workplace a tiny group of people
unaccountable to the rest of
the the employer whether that's an
individual a family a partnership or a
corporate board of directors tiny group
of people
controls economically a vast mass of
employees those employees don't elect
those people have no con nothing there
is no accountability it is the most
undemocratic
arrangement imaginable
and this society insists on calling
itself
democratic when it has organized the
minor matter of producing everything in
a in a way that isn't the direct it's
autocratic
so to push back on a few things so one
is the idea of this society calling
itself democratic is that the government
is elected democratically and the
government is able to pressure the
workplace through the process of
regulation you pass laws of the
boundaries of how
you know minimum wage
all those kinds of things that's the one
idea right the other is there is a
natural force within the capitalist
when there's no monopolies
of competition being the accountability
so if you're a shitty boss
the employ the employee in the capital
system has the freedom to move to
another company work for a better boss
so that that creates pressure on the
employers and the bosses that's at least
the idea that you uh there's two
boundaries of
you not misbehaving one is the law so
regulatory regulations by passed by the
government democratic and the second
is because there's always alternatives
in theory
then that puts pressure on everyone to
behave well because you can always leave
uh
so i mean that's kinds of accountability
but what you're saying is that does not
result in any in a
significant enough accountability where
the employer
that avoids exploitation of the worker
absolutely i mean whatever
accountability you get in those
mechanisms and
let me respond to that and then on the
counter argument um
first competition
here again we have to be hegelians just
a little
competition
destroys itself
it doesn't need any out the whole point
of competition is to beat the other guy
if i can produce the same product as the
other guy
either a better quality or a lower price
or maybe both
then i win because the customers will
come to me because my price is lower or
my quality is better and they'll leave
the other guy he'll go out of business
now let's follow when he goes out of
business because i've won the
competition
he fires his workers
i hire them because i'm now going to be
able to serve a market he can't serve
anymore so i'm gonna i'm gonna buy the
used equipment i'm gonna
and thereby many
become few
monopoly is the product of competition
it's not the antithesis
it's the product
well
let's see that's where it comes from
well there's another there's another
element to the system where there's
always a new guy that comes in
uh there isn't there isn't and that's
the that's the dream the entrepreneurial
spirit of a free
uh you know of of the of the united
states for example of a capitalist
system is
uh you can
be uh
broke and one day have a strong idea and
build up a business that takes on google
and facebook and twitter
and uh all the different
car ford gm which is what you know you
look at tesla for example right that's
the american dream uh one of the many
ideals of the american dream is you can
um
move
from
dirt poor to being the richest person in
the world right and um
it can happen it can happen but you're
you know what that's like that's like
you can win the lottery no that's not
quite no the lottery is complete luck
here you can work your ass off if you
have a larger better in the lottery
that's not that's not true there's a lot
of new businesses how many tesla's do
you do you know this is a really bad
example because the car company
the automotive sector is so difficult
to uh they operate at such a thin margin
of profit that they're probably a good
example of like capitalism just
completely coming to a halt in terms of
lack of innovation because you know
that's a very complicated industry
because of the supply chain there's so
much come on
they have their uniquenesses you're
quite right
but so does every other industry the one
thing that's common is that many become
few
what you can also have is when you have
a few
they jack up the price they make an
enormous profit and in the irony of
capitalism marx would love this they
begin to
incentivize people to break into this
industry because the few remaining are
making a wild amount of profit because
they are a few and can [ __ ] the market
to make it work like that for them
but the reason every
every small capitalist is trying to
build market share that's a police way
polite way of saying they want to become
a monopolist or to be more exact an
oligopolist one of a handful of firms
that dominates that's what they're there
for but yeah to push back a little bit
also because that's could be
this is a question also do you think
we're in danger of oversimplifying
capitalism
it completely removes the basic decency
of human beings
so
if you give me a choice
to press to press a button
to get rid of the competition and that
but that's going to lead to a lot of
suffering there's a lot of people at the
heads of companies that won't press that
button
that it's not in the calculation it's
not just money
it's human well-being too
so like
i think
i
yes
you and i don't live in the same place
though so you're saying that the forces
of capitalism take over in the minds of
the people at the top you got it and
then they they seized being human
essentially no this the basic okay i
wouldn't i wouldn't
depending on your model of humans yeah
but they they they lose track of the
better angels of their nature
and uh they just become cogs in the
machine but they're just happening to be
the company i would put it differently
that the system is so set up it's a
little bit like natural selection
the guys who may honor i could say the
women too it doesn't matter the people
who make it up through the layers of the
bureaucracy and get to the top in these
things have had to do things along the
way that become selective if they can't
stand it because they have that human
quality and there are people like i've
known them
they're the ones running an airbnb in in
vermont
they check they went there and they said
i'm not doing this anymore i'm not going
to treat people like that i'm going to
make a lovely place in vermont with my
husband or my wife or whatever and i'm
going to be you know enjoying the people
that come by and be a decent of course
of course but the system selects
the firm you know if you don't do what
has to be done to make the profit go up
you're toast there anyway the rest of
the people who vote for you are going to
kick you out you can tell them all day
long what a lovely person you are
they're going to look at you and wonder
what happened to you how did you even
get this far with the lovely person
horseshoe it's not okay okay okay okay
it's not necessarily just lovely person
so maybe
my i'll just say my bias is the people i
know
are
especially at the top of companies are
in the tech sector
where
innovation
is such a big part of it
so i think a lot of the things we're
talking about is when there's not much
innovation in the system
so
uh
innovation usually comes in the history
of capitalism innovation comes in spurts
there's the electric period the
chemistry period the nuclear period
there's now whatever you want to call it
the artificial intelligence or robotics
or computer it doesn't it comes and then
there's a flurry as everything is
reorganized around whatever the newest
technology is
and then you have a period where you can
get excited about that and the very rich
people who come to the top can talk
endlessly as they always do about
innovation
but again you know it it really is this
is a recurring
kind
uh
of debate and a recurring kind of issue
for me
how do i put this in a way
that
no i don't mean to offend so
please please no no i don't i don't want
to but
the problem with capitalism is
and maybe you'll like this the problem
with capitalism is
not that it is the one thing that's
consistent with human nature that's what
its defenders would like to have us
believe
but if anything i would argue the
opposite
that it is such a contradiction
to parts of our nature not other parts
that there it can never quite make it
there's always going to be the people
who don't go along with it people you're
talking about who do quit along the way
or maybe a few of them actually
make it to the top by god knows what
hook or what crook that they did it but
most of them go
and you know why because their humanity
is contradicted
by what it is they're being asked
to do
i mean the corporate sector this year
just to give you an
idea ceos uh are
jacking up their
their wage package they're already out
of whack i mean the average ceo pay is
now three three hundred times what the
average worker pays but they're jacking
it up even more why because that's
what's happening in their universe
that's what they're all doing it and
they have to do each one of them
justifies that i have to do that
otherwise i'd lose my guide to the next
one which of course is true but there's
no comfort for the mass of people who
aren't ceos for whom this argument isn't
very exciting uh so
there are
they're doing that at a time when the
american people can't cope they've just
gone through the covet disaster
they've gone through the worst second
worst economic crash of capitalism in
our history
after two years of this one-two punch
they got an inflation
a third punch and we are now predicting
rising interest rates in a recession at
the end of the year or early next year
you can't do this to a working class
when this was done to the german worker
class in the 1920s hitler was the result
you keep doing that in this country
we're already watching it you're going
to get that too you're already getting
bits and pieces you can't so there's a
quiet suffering amidst the working class
that's growing taking out on it can turn
to anger some little 18 year old kid who
has to go
three hours in his car and blow away
people in a supermarket
and it happens every day in this country
every day
so the that anger rises up in those
little ways now and bigger
potentially
by the way there's one more thing
on the rationality and this goes to elon
musk
if you're interested
49 000 people were killed in automobile
accidents this last year the number was
just released yesterday 49 000.
automobiles are the single largest
pollutant in the country they use up an
enormous amount of energy
they uh they use up enormous on our
resources
there is a way to make transportation
much more rational
and we've known it for decades it's
called mass transportation it's a really
beautifully maintained crystal clear
clean frequent system of buses trains
street rod
trolleys
uh vans
it could easily be done in this society
in fact i once did a
project that i estimated cost 30 billion
dollars
that's less than we're sending to
ukraine
to do this to reconfigure it uh a public
transit system where everywhere in this
country all the major metropolis this
country's overwhelmingly metropolitan
area well it really has to be more than
30 billion but but well it was a few
years ago
you're saying it's but i'm using a lot
of that's insane right it's not crazy
stuff it's a reasonable number right
right hey listen um but there's a and
we'll let me just finish the point sure
yes okay
so
i'm trying to be rational here
if we have a climate crisis which
everyone tells me we do
if it's got a lot to do with fossil
fuels which everybody tells me it has to
do
and and with the use of the fossil fuel
particularly for the automobile
then the solution to the problem would
be mass transit
we don't we're doing nothing to make
that happen nothing
well there's you know on um
you could argue that autonomous vehicles
is a kind of public transit because it's
going to be reusable vehicles it will
end
in theory uh car ownership so you just
have a more kind of distributed public
transit if it happens but you know that
that's a side effect his major goal and
the major goal of the other companies
that are busy
squeezing to get his share pie smaller
so they have some for general motors
toyota all of them are making electric
cars though
so what they've done is they've replaced
the individual car with fossil fuel with
another individual car yeah that's
[ __ ] nuts what are you doing one
that's one of the things they're doing
but automation is also another one but
on the elon side there's also
hilariously named boring company yes
which is working on tunnels which is
actually expanding the
the the the flexibility you might have
to start playing with ideas of public
transit right i think listen i'm now
partially living in austin texas that i
don't know if they know what a public
transit system is period yes um there's
most americans pick up trucks yeah
they're well there's this is an
interesting
so
the older by the way footnote the older
the city the more likely it has public
transportation
so you're saying boston is the best
example yes you have you been well yeah
yeah of course yeah i have a place in
boston boston with the street railway
boston is your case study of how to do
this because they've been doing it all
along new york is pretty good too
there's a trade-off yeah new york i
would say is better than boston because
there's you know
their technology also helps you out to
do the public transit better uh oh it's
almost like boston is a little too old
but yes i get your point uh but there is
a
the the ford f-150 pickup truck
symbolizes something about america and
and there is a practical nature to the
fact
that in order to do public transit in
order to do some of these things that
you're talking about with
the working class there has to be a
central planning component
or there has to be a centralized
component and america is very much
based on the idea of at least in recent
times i would say from the founding of
individualism
of respecting individual freedom
are you worried that
in order to bring some of these ideas of
marxism to life
you would trample on individual freedoms
no
sure for me marxism is
a way to enhance
the individual freedom of the mass of
people who have had that freedom eroded
under the capitalist so that's
a motive for my marxism it was for marx
too he loved the french revolution he
loved the liberte egalite fraternity the
great three and then democracy uh the
american contribution if you like he
believed in all of that his critique of
capitalism was it promised it
and then never delivered it and the
reason you have to go beyond it is
because it didn't deliver what it had uh
promised so for me um
it is the fulfillment of
of a gen but
again i'm a hegelian marxist so if you
want
individualism
for me is not the way it's set up in
this society some sort of antithesis
to the government
i think an immense con
has been pulled on the american people
and the khan works like this
you know what's bad and what's dangerous
and threatens you
it's the government the government's
going to come in and tell you what to do
the government's going to run your life
the government's the problem there
really is no other way to explain the
following in american politics
large numbers of people lose their homes
in a downturn like the so-called great
recession of 2008.
who do they blame the government
large numbers of people go unemployed
and what is the media all about the
government
if i were a capitalist i'd love this
i kick the workers by throwing them out
of their home and they don't get angry
at me they read the government
i fire large numbers of people i have no
responsibility for what happens to them
as a result of having no job and no
income and they get angry at the senator
i'm laughing all the way to the bank
this is a genius stroke in theory but
if you look at government because you
said accountability and the capitalist
system has no accountability there's
some pushback i give on the
accountability i think there is some
accountability work can discuss in a
hegelian way who
there's more accountability
for i would say that in theory
government is
perfectly accountable that's the whole
point of a democratic system
is you vote people in in practice right
there's a giant growing bureaucracy
that is accountable only on the surface
there's two parties
that seem to the same are the same media
somehow
integrated into making the the the same
two parties as you're just wearing
different colored shirts
uh to seem like they're very opposed and
are arguing and bitterly arguing and
calling each
nasty names and all those kinds of
things okay but that's government
so
uh
what exactly is worse
government or or companies well why are
we asking that question well these are
twins look
what you were what you were able to say
about republicans and democrats just now
with which i agree yeah i would say the
same thing about corporations and the
government this is the same people
literally let's go to churchill which
one is the which of course let's go to
churchill like democracy is the worst
form of government except all the other
ones or whatever so this kind of same
idea
which one exactly is worse because to me
it seems like which one between what
government and uh industry and companies
it's because government
is plagued by
um
i would call it corruption because the
corruption of
bureaucratic paperwork and then because
but they're not accountable it doesn't
seem to be our serious accountability
again
we're not seeing we're not living on the
same planet
the greatest practitioners of central
planning
are corporations
elon has an
operation like general motors ford ibm
or any of the other mega corps
they have to plan
they buy
up companies
because they don't want to deal in the
market they don't want the insecurity
the uncertainty of having to buy their
inputs or sell their outputs to somebody
they don't control
they want the professor to teach the
genius of a market they hate the market
and when they grow to be big they keep
buying whoever they were dealing with
before so they could better control them
which requires them then to plan
the production and distribution of goods
inside rather than buying them in the
market
the model of the government
is the private corporation
i have spent my life give you an example
in american universities big ones famous
not just as a student but as a professor
i mean half a dozen school i teach now
it's a new school here it's another one
right
they will model themselves after
businesses
they model their
you can attack the bureaucracy of
universities good reason it's a mess
but they're proudly modeling themselves
on organizing their bureaucracy in a
business-like manner
so you're looking at a difference which
isn't there
the government and the private sector
are partners and both of them wouldn't
have it any other way the corporations
want that from the government and the
government now knows that to please the
corporations is the number one objective
they have because that's how they keep
their jobs and keep their system going
and so for all practical purposes this
is
this is the same people but there's a
important differences
that
uh i don't know if they're fundamental
or just a consequence of history but if
you have government
they're accountable in a different way
than companies companies are accountable
by
especially if you have a consumer
they're accountable by sort of consumer
spending or not spending their money on
whatever the heck the company is selling
right the government is accountable by
votes
and it seems like
government unlike companies for most of
companies history are is always too big
to fail meaning it can always just print
money
it can always save itself and that
creates a bureaucracy
you never
you rarely pay the cost
of having made bad decisions if you're
in government you distribute the blame
and it's very unclear who's responsible
for bad decisions so bad decisions in
government accumulate so you become more
and more and more inefficient and
more and more poor in your decision
making in terms of you said public
transit should we build a public transit
system in this city or not that's a
difficult decision that's an interesting
decision
i would say it's very often a very good
decision
but
whoever makes that decision should be
accountable for a good or bad decision
and it seems like companies are more
accountable they pay
they feel the pain
of having made a bad decision more
because it can go bankrupt they i mean
there's much more day-to-day pressure to
make good engineering decisions
government doesn't seem to be under the
same level of pressure i is do do you
disagree with that i disagree with that
everything in my history
pushes me
you may be living i may be living in a
different uh
who knows a planet
or or taking a different sort of drug i
won't i won't mention the name but
i
i personally had a lot to do with a very
large company here in the united states
here in the new york area
and um
it involved two brothers and a family
who built it up into a huge corporation
one of the brothers was
kind of the dynamo
of the family
and he was more responsible than anybody
else building it up
but he took care of his brothers he had
a nice feeling about his brother so
the one brother who could not
you know without help tie his shoes
became a vice president
got an enormous salary
got a beautiful office in a skyscraper
uh not that many blocks from where i'm
sitting right now
and
that was the way that
family handled that company
and all of his relatives that were
somewhere in this company doing a
variety of whatever
because
and my experience with this
and because i went to the schools i told
you
all my experiences with that group of
people corporately say full of those
stories
you know
they made mistake after mistake which
they would tell you about
didn't didn't undermine their they were
always able to blame
somebody else something else
that scraped them through and had they
not been able to they would have been
replaced by another person who did the
same thing for as long as they could
and they knew it
they would talk about it at family
that's how i
know yeah that's i mean that i
understand that you want the outside
world to look at it this way but
well not my experience
interest but again what's
that kind of thing
uh at the risk of saying human nature
again i wonder what
kind of system
allows for that more versus versus less
this is the question of
i would call that let's put that under
the umbrella term of corruption
which system allows for more corruption
remember that the way i defined a
different system is not more or less
government it's more or less allowing a
democratic workplace yeah reconfiguring
it what what happens when everybody
has a vote when you have to explain
what the strategies are what the
alternatives are to a larger number of
people than a board of directors or uh
major shareholders or whoever it is that
most companies are responsible to
and now you've got a whole different
universe it's not a small group of
people can't be hidden the way it's
normally hidden most of it and on and on
and on this is you know worker co-ops is
what this is called in many parts of the
world so it's not that i'm advocating
something that's never been seen before
not at all
the marxism i understand is to
pick from historical precedence the
things that we think will work better
and i think if all the people in an
enterprise just to drive the point home
democratically decided they would never
give
two or three individuals 100 million
dollars while everybody else can't send
their kid to college everybody that can
do that
uh so just to return just to address
this
uh point about the particular
implementation of marxism that was the
early days right in the soviet union
why did
stalinism for example lead to so much
bloodshed do you think and human
suffering is there any elements
within the ideas of marxism
that catalyzed
the kind of government
the kind of system that led to that
bloodshed
i don't think so i think there were many
things that led to the bloodshed and all
that stalin's regimes did
and
you know i spent
10 years of my life
with another economist writing a book
about that to try to explain from a
marxist position
the rise and fall of the soviet union
you might want to take a look at it
sometime but
there i'm going to say a few things now
but all of those things are spelled out
in great detail with loads of empirical
evidence etc um in that uh in that work
so let me start with you know playing a
little bit with with hegel um
the biggest impact
that marxism had
on the soviet union
was really not so much what the soviet
union did
but what the rest of the world did
i mean you had a really interesting
move uh and i'll give you a parallel
from
today
the move was
that
the old russian regime collapsed
world war one just it fell apart the
czar and all of that
it couldn't it couldn't survive it had
already been in trouble there was a
revolution in 1905 there was the loss of
the war to japan i mean if you know
russian history which i assume you do um
you'll know that there was a lot leading
up to
the collapse in in 1917
and in some ways it was fortuitous that
the
political group very small that could
seize the opportunity of that collapse
happened to be marxists you know
earlier on with karensky the first
government that tried
it wasn't people all that impressed by
marxism there was people more skeptical
and
would not have been called marxists
probably in
by history
they couldn't they tried they couldn't
lenin and his associates
were able to take over from them later
in that same year
the rest of the world though was
horrified
the rest of the world
saw marxism having taken this immense
leap
from being a political party a
movement critical of capitalism yes
but still not
challenging the power now it had the
power and in a big country
and they freaked out
uh if you know american history uh this
country the leadership of this country
went completely berserk i mean we had a
repression of the left the likes of
which we had not seen before sat the 20s
were a time of palmer raids in in boston
the sacko vanzetti uh trials i mean
really
grim
hostility and you had the four countries
agreeing to invade the soviet union to
try to crush the revolution the u.s
britain france and japan all attacked 10
000 american troops
so what you had right away was a notion
in the west
that
this was
this was unthinkable this was there was
a great professor at princeton um
meyer forget his first name
who wrote this wonderful book
about all american foreign policy since
1917 has been obsessed
with russia even now this this fight
with ukraine is half about russia as if
russia still was the soviet union as if
people haven't figured out
that was a big change back in 1989 and
90. you know yeltsin and and putin are
not what what you had before or at least
they're not lenin um they may not be so
different from some of the other but in
any case
um
so you had one
factor was the utter isolation the utter
condemnation the global i mean
rosa luxemburg
is i mean i i assume you know the rosa
luxemburg is hunted down in the streets
of berlin she's a critic of lenin's by
the way but she's a leftist hunted down
and hacked into bits
killed so you're attributing some
he's surrounded some of the bloodshed
to the fact that basically the rest of
the world turned away
turned against turn against sort of
eternal guess is the better very
yeah i mean not in order of importance
but it's
it's a very important part of the
psychology of being you know
it's what you would call paranoid if
there weren't quite as much evidence
that indeed there was a lot to be afraid
of at that time nobody had ever done it
look you could see the effects of it by
stalin inventing the idea
which had no support at first
that you could have socialism in one
country that was thought to be
ridiculous that socialism was
internationalism marx was it marx was
against capitalism everywhere it was you
know uh workers of the world unite not
workers of russia unite
workers of the
he had to
go through a procedure of kind of coming
to terms with the fact that the
revolution he had in russia which was
tried in berlin was tried in munich was
tried in budapest was tried in seattle
here they all failed they all fit and
he's left
so the french would say
right yeah all along
um that's one
the second thing is economic isolation
russia is a poor country
and it needed
what it got before the war which were
heavy investments from the french and
the germans particularly but others too
now this was all cut off
and you can see the replay with the
sanctions progress it's
we're going to do it again we're going
to do it again we have to do we we have
the world is different and the sanctions
don't work but
they're going to try them they're going
to try
because it's the history but that
culture was
it's today is completely different
russia's a different place today but
russia has china and that changes
everything and they don't get that here
yet but they will yeah there's a very
complicated dynamic with china even with
india yep um but portuguese sorry brazil
yeah sorry to say human nature may
change at a slower pace yes
that has occurred to me as well i i get
that point so is there
can you steal man the case
or consider the case that there's
something about the implementation of
marxism
maybe because of the idealistic nature
of focusing on the working class and
workers unite
that naturally
leads to formation of a dictatorial
force a dictator
that says let us temporarily
give power to this person
to manage some of the details of how to
run the democracy
uh of
giving voice to the workers so that they
get to choose and then that naturally
leads to dictator and there's naturally
inhuman nature
power and absolute power as the old
adage goes
corrupts absolutely is it possible that
whenever you focus on marx's ideals
you're going to end up with a dictator
and often
when you give too much power to anyone
human a small number of people you're
going to get into huge amount of trouble
you you've pushed things together there
that i would
i think if you if you give putch there's
a good yeah
uh german um
the uh if you i remember i told you my
mother was born in germany and and then
your dad is french
yeah but he was born in mets if you know
european it's a city on the border of
france and germany if you come from this
al alsatian
in german so they're german speaking for
absolutely both
it's a bilingual because
it's been back and forth so many times
in medieval days already that it
literally you go from one store to
another the proprietor here is french
and the proprietor there is german but
they all speak both languages because
you don't speak either of them i speak
russian russian but not german ukrainian
no j i took french for four years in
high school but i've forgotten all of it
i i remember the romance and the spirit
of the language but not the details i'm
sure i can remember um
if you allocate power
unequally
undemocratically
and you do it for a very long period of
time
and you do it on
many levels of ideology
it is not surprising that it sticks and
it stays and you can make a political
revolution or even an economic
revolution
and you will discover it has a life of
its own and it's going to take a long
time before people don't if you have a
religious tradition christianity
that prides itself on its
monotheism
and that it doesn't want to have
anything to do with the old greek
mythologies when there was zeus and
diana and all the others and they were
very human-like but instead we have one
who is the absolute beginning in it yeah
what are you doing you're teaching
people
an authority line that comes from the
individual if you have a sequence of
kings if in your feudal manner the lord
sits
called the landlord and he has
unspeakable power
over everything that goes on
and you do this for thousands of years
yeah you can make a russian revolution
in 1917 but if you imagine you've gotten
away from all that people assume without
ever thinking about it
you're gonna have
trouble stalin is figured
here
as the originator of his situation he
wasn't he had never had that power he
may have thought that but i don't
he's the product look the cuban people
made fidel
who really wasn't that kind of guy you
know he's a baseball playing lawyer
that's what he was yeah but they made
him into
tallahassee so it's not
uh no no no it's it was the systems
feudalism the nature it was the
structures and institutions that
cultivated in people a mentality that
has its own rhythm and doesn't take
doesn't
follow the calendar of a political
revolution that's the fundamental
question is there's something about
communism
that creates some mentality that
enables somebody like stalin or mao
no i think it's the social issues and
problems the society has that make them
then go to what they find familiar to
what seems to make sense and he's the
guy look let me give you an example from
american history
the republican party has traditionally
in this country been the party of
private enterprise and minimum
government
incomes trump runs for office in 2016
is elected okay what does he do he
commences the most massive
tax increase
and the most massive government
intervention
in the world of of economics that we've
had for dec
nobody says anything
the republicans
gave
and the democrats largely too
they cave he can he can
he can throw a tariff on anything he
gets up in front of the american people
and he says the chinese will pay the
tariff
that's not what a tariff is it's not how
a tariff works
he he would flunk a co a freshman course
in economics which everybody knows
everybody who teaches these courses no
it doesn't matter
he's still calling the shots
what is going on here is that a society
has come to a point where it can't solve
its problems and it begins what to tap
into older
forms and all of the laissez-faire and
all of the individualism
and suddenly the republican party is
gung-ho and now they're going to make
abortion illegal the government is
telling you what you can do with your
uterus
what
what
the government is being given more and
more and more and more power they're
hoping what do they like the government
no
they're desperate this is not a
pro-government
and it wasn't in russia isla they were
in a desperate fix
and so
and he took advantage
so to which degree did
would you say marx
marx's ideas
led to the creation of the
uh national socialism party of german
workers hence the nazi party the fascist
party in the 30s and the 40s
at the head of whom was
uh hitler which i just recently learned
he was uh employee number seven of the
party or whatever the seventh person to
have joined the party and have created
one of
the most uh consequential and powerful
political parties in the history of the
20th century what degree did mark's
ideas
marxism ideas have to play it is the
national
socialist
party of german workers right
workers naturalistic such
german worker party worker party
national socialist german worker party
so well here's the history
does he care about the world or did he
just use the workers as a populist
message the only thing that marxism did
for mr hitler was provide him
with his stepping stone to power but it
had nothing no other he didn't know
anything about it didn't care anything
about it nor did the people around him
here's the story of what happened there
uh which i know largely through my own
family and plus my own history the work
that i did
um
the most successful socialist party in
europe was the german party
it started around 1870 marxist was still
alive some of his own family were
leaders fernando lasalle and other his
daughters
by the end of the century it was the
second most important party in germany
nobody understood it it was overwhelm it
was almost as big a shock
to the europeans as was the russian
revolution in 1917. here was a political
party that was now in every german city
in every german town
powerful
and enjoying its rise up uh that's my
family is involved in this so i mean i
really do know the story
it meant that starting
around 19678
if you wanted to have any kind
of presence
in the german working class
you had to use the word socialist you
had to otherwise
they wouldn't pay attention
the other parties call themselves
catholic
uh germany is divided the upper truth
the northern two-thirds is protestant
the southern third is catholic munich
and bavaria it's catholic and every
other part of germany basically is
protestant um you could be in the
catholic party that was the south
or you could be in various conservative
prussian and other but if you wanted to
have a presence in the working class
which was growing every i mean in
germany a very powerful capitalist
country expanding like crazy at this
time you know germany was the major
competitor to britain for the empire the
united states was it was coming up too
but it was germany and us taking over
from britain's empire so the german
working class was it
so anybody who wanted to approach
the working class in whatever way
had to come to terms and be friendly to
socialism
other parties did this too just like
hitler they put the word socialist in
their party but they wanted to make it
clear that they weren't
uh
anything to do with the soviet union or
anything to do with marxism so they put
the word national nazi is the first four
letters of national nazional in german
nazis how you spell
national in the german national
socialism but definitely not communists
that's right they killed coming they
they fought communists in the street
they they had pitched battles
they literally threatened each other's
existence and their life and the first
people that he arrested and put in jail
were not jews and gypsies and all the
other people he eventually killed it was
communists
they were the the number one socialists
right behind them why because up until
he takes power january of 1933 that's
when hitler takes power the last
elections two of them in 1932
the socialists and communists the vote
together 50 of the vote in germany so
he appealed to the the german
uh manufacturer the german capitalist
and he said
the communists and socialists are going
to win
you won't and you you're just the
capitalist you have too few people
you need a mass base and i'm the only
one that can do that
and there's just the populist message
that he used that's right but it was
explicitly done as a deal the the the
ruling group said to hindenburg the old
prussian man who was in charge of the
german government at the time you have
to invite hitler to form a new
government otherwise he would never have
done he had called hitler nasty names
before the prussian aristocracy looked
down on hitler as an awes little funny
man with a mustache who was austria
wasn't even german you know
for them that mattered so
he he comes in as the enemy
the smasher of socialism and communism
which he immediately does
only people who don't know or care about
the history
pick up on the word
you know it's like
there are people here in the united
states who like to say
we are not a democracy we are republic
which is like saying i'm not a banana
i'm a fruit
you have to explain to these people
so you have to explain to people yes
we're a republic
but we have a commitment to democracy as
a way to govern the republic because to
say you're a republic doesn't imply what
kind of government you have to go
through that with people so they kind of
get it and certain words have power
beyond their actual meaning that's used
in communication whether it's negative
like racist or positive like freedom of
speech or democrat or death
yeah and then you use that to mean
something who knows or negative uh what
stop donnie stop being a socialist yeah
or some whatever what whatever that
means that's not even used as in any
kind of philosophical economic uh sense
so let's fast forward to today right you
mentioned bernie sanders right
uh there's another popular figure that
represents some ideas of maybe let's
call it democratic socialism and maybe
let's try to start
sneak up on a definition of what that
could possibly mean but aoc
alexandria ocasio-cortez she's from uh
these parts yes queens
uh so maybe if you can comment on bernie
sanders or aoc
um are they open to some ideas and and
marxism
are they representing those ideas well
in both the economic and the political
sense
okay um
where do i begin this yeah the social
the socialist movement predates marx
was always larger than marx
and has gone on to develop
separately after marx's death
so can we pause on that actually can you
is there a nice way to
to
delineate draw a line between marxism
and socialism or or
if if marxism is kind of a part of
socialism
can you speak to like
maybe try to define once again what
marxism is
and what socialism is right
marxism is a
systematic
analysis
heavily focused on economics
and as i said earlier
devoted to
mostly
a critique
of capitalism
and that's its strength how it does that
how it poses the questions how it
analyzes the way capitalism works
that is really the forte of the marxist
tradition
socialism is a bigger broader tent
within which marxism
uh figures it's there
so that people who aren't marxists are
nonetheless aware of marxism uh
like it more or less study it more or
less uh but it's a broader notion
that i like to use this sentence to
describe
it's a broad idea that we can do better
than than capitalism that really
there are all kinds of things about
capitalism
that are not
what we as modern citizens of the world
uh think are adequate that we are in a
tradition
that goes back to all the people who
thought they could do better than
slavery and all the people who thought
they could do better than feudalism
uh we've made progress feudalism was a
progress over slavery
capitalism was a progress over both of
them
and progress hasn't stopped and we are
the people who
in a variety of ways
want
the progress
to go further further and are not held
back by believing that capitalism is
somehow the best beyond which we cannot
go or even think we find that to be
in the worst sense of the word
a reactionary way of thinking and we're
that large
community many of us are not interested
in economics all that much we don't
think that's
the focal area we are socialists for
example because we want to do something
to deal with climate change to to we
think the world is about to kill itself
um uh physically and we want to take
steps with other people to stop that to
to fix that etc etc
so that that's for me uh a kind of
difference
it's a little difficult to say because
there's no other figure
like marx
that has an equal
um impact and equal place within the
broad socialist tradition
and the only tradition that comes close
might be
the anarchist tradition but that's very
specialized and
that's a whole nother kind of
conversation and whatever you say the
influence of the great anarchist
thinkers uh krapotkin bakunin
um sorel and fran and others
still doesn't amount to the impact that
marx and marxism have had so far that
could change but i mean up to this point
um that's the
um
i think that's a way of understanding
the relationship yeah that's interesting
that the some of the ideas within
anarchism and of course it's a one of
the more varied
um disciplines right because there's
such
maybe by definition such variety in
their thinkers but they kind of stand
for a uh
dismantling of a power center
and that
if not equates tends to rhyme with some
of the ideas of socialism absolutely so
where you have the
you know there's a whole train of
thought in socialist ideas any marxist
ideas
that uses the phrase quote the withering
away of the state
that's a quotation from lenin
uh people should understand that's a
quotation from lenin
and it was made by lenin positive in
other words lenin was saying that's a
good thing that's something we stand for
we want to create the conditions under
which there is a way because you
remember the the the communists or
whatever they won't call that at first
in russia before the revolution they
were just socialists they were hunted
down and persecuted by the government
left and right they had no love for the
government the government was their
literal everyday enemy
and uh
being critical of government
didn't just mean this particular
government but of the whole
being a marxist you always ask the
questions of the social constitution of
whatever it is you're struggling against
so there was this interest why is the
state so important especially because if
you understand
feudalism particularly early feudalism
it didn't have powerful states
one of lenin's greatest books is called
the economic history of russia and he
goes back centuries it's a huge book
three or four inches thick
and i'm one of the few people who've
read it
and
he's very good about the absence
of a strong central government in many
parts of feud including inside russia
but also in other parts of europe the
development of a powerful central state
comes towards the end of feudalism as it
is desperate to hold on which ought to
be suggestive that maybe the turn to
powerful governments here in the united
states or in europe
is maybe also because this system is
exhausted and can't go on and has to
marshal every last
bit of power it can
not to be
lost in history it would be interesting
to see what the soviet union would look
like if lenin never died right
a lot of people have asked that question
over the years a lot of people
there is stalin sliding in in the middle
of the night erasing the withering away
of the state part yes exactly uh so just
to return briefly back to aoc and bernie
sanders what are your thoughts about
these modern political figures that
represent some of these ideas and they
sometimes refer to those ideas as
democratic socialism right
the crucial thing about bernie and about
aoc and it's particularly true about
bernie
because aoc is much younger and bernie's
an older man
bernie
being roughly my age
has been around
formatively as a student as an activist
and then coming up through the ranks in
in burlington vermont as a mayor and all
the rest
um
he lived through what for lack of a
better term i would call cold war
america and the taboo in cold war
america running from around 1945 six
to the present i mean really never
stopped
um
was
a manichaean
world view the united states is good it
defines democracy and the soviet union
is awful it defines whatever the
opposite of democracy
should be called um good here evil there
it was taken so far
that
even in among the ranks of
academic individuals
it was impossible
to talk have a conversation i mean
i can't tell just make it very personal
the number of times i would raise my
hand in my classes at harvard or
stanford or yale
um
and i would ask a question that had
something to do with marxism because i
was studying it on my own there were
there were no courses to teach this to
me except by people who trashed that you
know that other than that and i didn't
want that
um
so i would ask a question
and i would see in the faces of my
teachers
both those i didn't much care for and
those who were good teachers that i
liked
fear it was just fear they didn't want
to go there they didn't want to answer
my question and i after a while i got to
know some of them and i found out why
because you don't know how the rest of
the class is going to understand this
either they would have to say i don't
know which would be the honest truth for
many of them but a professor does not
want to say in a classroom i don't know
this is not cool
or they'd have to if they knew
they'd have to say something
that indicated they didn't know really
much and they weren't even to do that or
they would know something
and maybe that would be because
they were interested
they did not want the rest of the
students to begin to say oh you know
professor smith
um well you know he's interested
it's not good for your career you don't
know how this is going to play out who's
going to say what to whom
and i could see in their faces what i
later learned because they told me don't
come to my office hours you we're in the
office we can talk about it but i'm
that's how bad it was
is is it not still pretty much
in my field the great so-called debate
i mean i find it boring but the great
debate for my colleagues
is between what's called neoclassical
economics and keynesian economics
neoclassical the government should stay
out of the economy
let's say fair or old liberalism and the
keynesians saying no you you crazy
neo-classical if you do that you'll have
great depressions and the system will
collapse you need the government to come
in to solve the problems to fix the
weaknesses
and they hate each other and they throw
each other out of their jobs
one of the very few things they can do
together that they agree on is keeping
people like me out
that they can find common ground uh to
do so i had to learn it all on myself
why am i telling you this because
this taboo
means that all of the complicated
developments within
marxism and within socialism
of the post-world war ii period the vast
bulk of all of that is unknown
not just to the average american person
but to the average american academic to
the average american who thinks of
himself or herself as an intellectual i
mean i i have had to spend ridiculous
amounts of my time
explaining soviet history they have no
idea
or
saying there's this man lukach a
hungarian marxist he really had
interested
or to explain that gramsci was not a
great literary critic he was head of the
communist party of italy for most of his
adult life
what does that mean
why you like gramsci as a literary
critic but um uh they were and they
didn't even know they don't even know
it's been erased
it's a little bit like stories i've
heard about trotsky and his influence
kind of erased in the soviet union
because he he obviously fell out of
favor and so somehow all of his writings
many of which are very interesting and
complicated uh anyway so
what you're going to have in this
country is a slow
awakening of socialism
from a long hibernation called the cold
war
i never expected to be very honest with
you that i would live to see i knew it
would come
because these things always do
but i didn't expect to see it so i have
been surprised
as have a lot of us
that when it starts to happen it happens
fast
so the uh you see bernie is an early
sign of the the awakening absolutely
to
accept the answer he was always a social
we all knew and everybody who paid
attention he didn't hide it
but 2016 he go he makes a decision
momentous to run for president he's just
a senator from vermont vermont is one of
the smallest states in the union
people who live in vermont love to tell
you that there are more cows than people
in vermont et cetera et cetera
uh so here from this little state this
elderly gentleman with a new york city
accent
runs for or and says i'm a socialist and
when they attack him he doesn't run away
i'm a socialist i'm a socialist now he
had been it wasn't that it wasn't the
secret that suddenly got out
but the great question and i don't mind
telling you because i went to the right
schools
i know a lot of people you know you know
janet yellen was my classmate at yale
and stuff like that so
i was speaking with a high official of
the democratic party and i said well
what do you think about bernie
entering the race
makes no difference they get one percent
of the vote
right he was wrong yeah they had no idea
what was coming but the truth is i
didn't either it wasn't just that he
didn't get it i thought his one percent
was probably right so we were both wrong
yeah change can happen fast do you think
aoc might be president one day yeah
possible possible and but
two things number one
it's fast
number two
it's going to go in the following
direction i would guess
you begin
with the most
moderate
calm
non-confrontational socialism you can
imagine so not aoc or bernie
no no they they are not confrontational
in my judgment in terms of the ideas of
socialism i mean they're both very
feisty they're feisty personally but not
but not ideologically
you know she is
bernie is also
you know in in honest moments
and they both really are pretty honest
folks at least in my experience um
in honest moments bernie will tell you
that his what he advocates as democratic
socialism is pretty much what fdr was in
the 1930s
it was a kind of popular
government
tax the rich a lot more than you do now
to provide a lot more support for the
working class than you do now
that's not a fundamental change that's
what he means by socialism when he talks
about it and he's asked for examples he
mentions denmark a lot okay that that
that's consistent that
that's the softest kind of socialism and
that's where we're going to start in a
country coming out of hibernation
pretty soon it's already happening
there'll be people who need and want to
go further in the direction of socialism
than bernie and aoc are comfortable with
you could already see that the shoots of
it now you know aoc voted
together with most of the others to
support the money for ukraine
okay that a lot of people in the in the
socialist movement do not support that
uh and that's gonna i don't know exactly
how that's gonna work out but
that should give people an idea there
are disagreements and they're gonna
fester and they're gonna think they
don't the people
so people in the socialist sphere don't
support money from the united states in
the large amounts that it is being sent
to ukraine is it because of it's a
fundamentally the military-industrial
complex is a capitalist institution kind
of thing
no i wonder what the i mean there's some
people for whom that's the issue then
there are people for whom
this is you know it's guns and butter
and why are we
why are we over there when we have such
needs at home that are being neglected
yeah and then there are people who
well go back to what we talked about the
beginning who are more like lenin and
debs
this is this is a fight between
western capitalism and russian
oligarchs and
and wannabe oligarchs in ukraine and
what are we doing here
we have to insist that these
forces
sit down at the bargaining table and
negotiate a settlement don't kill large
numbers of ukraine i mean everybody's
willing to fight to the last ukrainian
is a little strange here what are you
doing
you're supposed to be in favor of peace
you know and for the united states which
just finished
invading and occupying afghanistan and
iraq to be against another country
invading i mean who in the world is
going to take this seriously this is
crazy that you know i invade it's good
and you invade is terrible
what
you know what are you doing
why are you doing that what what what's
what's going on here all of these
questions are being active by the way
not just by socialists by lots of other
people too inside the democratic party
and also inside the republican party
you watch that tucker carlson or people
like that they are against the stuff in
in ukraine they don't want the money
spent there they don't want the weapons
sent there they don't like the whole
policy it's e and trump wobble so
mr biden's policy has got all kinds of
critics on the left and the right and
every day that this thing lasts these
criticisms get bigger anyway the point
is that aoc
and
bernie
should be i think evaluated as the early
shoots
after a long winter of cold war
uh
isolation from the whole
you know when i explained to people the
the the contribution made for example to
modern marxism i'll give you an example
by the the french philosopher luis
altucere i don't know if the name means
anything to you okay
he was the rector of the ecole normale
superior in paris that's the equivalent
imagine in this country if there were a
university that combined harvard yale
princeton and mit i mean it would be the
universe well the ecole normale in
france in paris is the
he was a tenured professor who became
the rector director is like the
president of the university
an active member of the french communist
party most of his adult life
that was possible in france during the
cold war
that was unthinkable in this country but
you could not in a million years right
so
i
aldesair as a philosopher
tried to bring a version of
post-modernism
into marxism with enormous
impact all over the world where he
traveled
uh not just in europe all over all right
so if you want to look him up i'll spell
it out for you sure
a-l-t-h-u-s-s-e-r
luis the louis l-o-u-i-s luis altucere
look them up you'll see tons of stuff by
the way mit press is a major publisher
if i remember of his works in english
um
by the way the textbook i wrote in
economics in case you're ever interested
was also published by the mit press and
the title
of the contending economic theories
neoclassical keynesian and marxian
that's
marxian yeah that's right and by the way
when we think uh
i don't know if there's an interesting
distinction between marxian economics
and marxist
that's the mark i suppose marxism is the
umbrella yeah of everything that i only
use it because marxist
i use as a noun a person is a marxist
marxian i use as an adjective to qualify
but other i don't mean some great
different there's a last point i would
like to make about aoc and bernie that's
also general
i'm a historian too
and i know
that the transition out of feudalism in
europe to capitalism
was a transition that took centuries
and that occurred in fits and starts so
for example
a feudal manner would start to
disintegrate serfs would run away they'd
run into a town
how would they live in the town they had
no land anymore because they had run
away from the feudal manor
a deal was struck without the people
involved in the deal understanding what
they were doing
a merchant
would say to one of these serfs
i'm in the business of buying and then
reselling stuff and living off the
difference
but you know i could make more money if
i produce some of this stuff myself
rather than buy it from somebody else so
i'm gonna i'm gonna make you a deal i'm
gonna give you money once a week i'll
give you a money what we would later
call a wage and you come here and under
my supervision you make this crap that
i'm gonna then sell
and this all works out in other words
there were there were efforts
unconscious
not self-aware
to go out of feudalism to a new system
some of them lasted a few days and then
fell apart
some of them lasted weeks or months or
years
but it took a long time
before the conditions were ready
for a kind of a general switch
and once that was done it grew on itself
and became the global capitalist system
we have today that's the only model we
have
so for me
that's what i see when i look at
socialism i see the paris commune was an
event an attempt
it lasted a few weeks
i see russia that was an attempt lasted
70 years
then i say you know fill in the blank i
see these are all early experiments
these are all you learn things to do
learn things never to do again the good
the bad what do you build on how do you
learn and that's what the socialist and
marxist tradition when it's serious
that's what it does so in your ideas
sort of capitalism was a significant
improvement over the feudalism yes uh
and
we are coming to an age and over slavery
and we're coming to an age where
capitalism will die out and make it's
not that capitalism is somehow
fundamentally broken it's better than
the things that came before it but there
is going to be things yet better and
they will be grounded in the ideas of
marxism and socialism
is there just just a linger briefly and
uh
the way
marxism is used as a term on twitter
uh
there's something called i'm sorry if
i'm using the terms incorrectly but uh
cultural
marxism right
criticisms of the universities
um being infiltrated by cultural
marxists
um i'm not exactly sure i don't
pay close enough
no no but it's woke it's yes there's a
there's a kind of woke ideology that i'm
not exactly sure right
it's not you that what is the
fundamental text
that was the karl marx of wokeness
all i do know is that there are certain
characteristics
of
woke ideology which is
hard lines are drawn between
the good guys and the bad guys
and uh and basically everyone is a bad
guy except except the people that are
very loudly non-stop saying that they're
the good guy and that applies
for for
for
racism for sexism
for uh gender
um all the gender politics identity
politics all that kind of stuff is there
is there any parallels between
marxian economics and marxist ideology
and whatever is being called marxism on
twitter
no not much
mostly marx you have to
one of the consequences of the taboo
after world war ii
is that marxism like socialism and
communism become swear words it's like
calling somebody
well i won't
use bad language but using a four-letter
word to describe somebody yes so instead
of calling them you know this or that
you call them a marxist in many circles
this
is even worse than whatever other
adjective you might have used but it
doesn't have a particular meaning
that i can assess the closest you get is
your little list
it is somebody who is concerned about
uh
race and sex and
sexual orientation and gender and all of
those things
and wants there to be trans gendered
bathrooms and that and i don't like any
of these people so i slapped the word
marxism or the phrase cultural marxism
because it isn't marxism about getting
more money or controlling the industry
or all those things that dimly we know
marxists somehow are concerned about so
this is odd since they don't know much
about martial and i've always been
interested in culture i mean lukacs the
man i mentioned to you before gramsci
that's what they're famous for the
analysis of what marxism particularly
has to say about culture gramsci writes
a great length about the catholic church
about
theater and painting in in italy and on
and on i mean
this is just ignorance talking they
don't know anything about that i don't
know what the names are
it's a it's a label
that summarizes kind of a shorthand i'm
against all of this i don't want to be
told
that there's ugly racism in this country
and it always has been or sexism or
um
phobia against gay people whatever it is
that's agitating them
i mean marxism or socialism maybe it's
just
it's like socialism is the post office
it is
it is a mentality but i don't blame them
i mean it's childish
it's mean-spirited
but it comes out of the fact no one ever
sat them down and said you know here is
this tradition it's got these kinds of
things that people kind of share and
these big differences look an
intelligent
society
which this country is
could have and should have done that it
was fear
and a kind of terror
that made them behave in the way they
did and we're now seeing it having said
that there is such a thing as cultural
marxism
what that is is
simply those marxists
who
devoted themselves
to analyzing how it is that a particular
culture is on the one hand
shaped by capitalism and on the other
hand it becomes a condition for
capitalism to survive and grow in other
words how do we analyze the interaction
between
uh
the class struggle on the job
and attitude towards sexuality or
movements in music or whatever else
culture and there are
george lucach this hungarian great name
in there the greatest of all the names
uh antonio gramsci and a modern name
just died a couple years ago a british
intellectual named stuart hall h-a-l-l
you want to if you want if if i were
teaching which i have done of course in
cultural marxism
those would be three
major
blocks on the syllabus i would give you
articles and books to read
of their stuff because it has been so
seminal in provoking uh many many others
so there is something to be said and
understood about the kind of culture
that capitalism creates and the kind of
culture that enables capitalism yes and
marxists are particularly those who like
to look at that interaction
in other words they're interested in how
capitalism shapes culture and how
culture shapes capitalism there's
another name i forgot um stuart hall is
british
gramsci is italian lucas is hungarian
um
the german is walter benjamin
m i b-e-n-j-a-m-i-n he was a member of
the frankfurt school which is a huge
school of marxism that developed in
frankfurt germany and that has a lot of
people many of whom were interested in
cultural questions it was a bit of a
reaction against
the narrow marxism that was so focused
on economics and politics there were
people who said you're leaving out
very important parts of modern society
that are shaping the economy as much as
they are shaped by it and it was that
impetus to open marxism to be more
inclusive in what it deemed to be
important to understand that this cult
and they call themselves cultural
marxists but they had a completely
different meaning from this this is just
uh
you know just bad-mouthing that's all
let me ask a more personal question so
for most of the 20th century no not most
but a large many decades in the united
states as a consequence of the cold war
and before
being a marxist is one of the worst
things you could be
have you had dark periods in your own
life where you've gone to some
dark places in your mind where it was
difficult
like self-doubt
difficult to know like what the hell am
i doing
when you're surrounded by colleagues and
people you said prestigious universities
both personal interests of career
but also as a human being when everybody
you know
kind of looks at you funny because
you're studying this thing
did that ever get you real low no
i know people that who had exactly what
you said i mean your question's
perfectly reasonable
uh if i were you i'd be asking me that
question too um
and what's wrong with you nothing wrong
with the question uh yeah
and here's the honest truth i don't know
how anomalous i am i really don't
but the truth is no i have
if my wife was sitting here she'd tell
you
what she tells me which is i have been
tremendously lucky in my life which is
true um
but then again luck never is the only
explanation for things
that's part of it
um
what can i say i didn't choose the time
of my birth i didn't choose the
communities in which i grew up or the
schools i attended or anything else no
but the fact that there was no courses
or extensive courses on marketing
economics but you know again it's i'm
hegel
on the one hand i was denied good
instruction
on the other hand i had to go out and
learn it on my own and the motivation
when you do that is very different i'm
not the student who sits there with my
notebook taking notes of what the great
professor says and reading the text and
getting ready for the exam i don't have
an exam
i ha and i'm doing something slightly
risque you know kind of yeah
romantically
different and oppositional
um
i was able to find always
one or two professors that i could talk
to outside of the classroom situation
other students who felt enough similar
to me that we could get together and
read these books and talk about them i
had a number of of really
fortuitous people who were kind to me
and and gave me of their time and their
effort to teach me along the way
um
and i've had the benefit that because i
went to all these fancy schools
i do know a lot of people who are in
high places in this culture and when i
have been put in difficult positions i
often wave my pedigree and it works like
garlic with the devil it back away they
back away
because americans are very deferential
to
that kind of academic prestige but
there's a personal psychological thing
that seems that you have never been
shaken by this you've uh
uh
just naturally somebody
um who just has perseverance
well i would put it i mean i understand
what you're saying but i would put it
differently i think
capitalism struck me early on in my life
as not that great a system
and nothing has happened to change my
mind in other words
the development
uh just
just kept giving me more and more
evidence yeah that this and i must say
over the last 10 years what's really
changed
the last 10 years i mean
i can't describe to you how big that
changes and and that may be more
important than anything else we've
discussed
up until 10 years ago
i would do a public event
an interview on television or a radio
thing or
give a talk at some
conference or something
once every two or three months i'd be
invited and i would do it like academics
often do
i now do two to three to four
interviews every day
so
uh there's a hunger
that wow is there anger
it's that you know and i want to be
honest with you
as i say at the end of some of my talks
i allow there to be a kind of a pregnant
pause
from the podium you know
that i lean into the microphone as i say
with as much smile as i can get i'm
having a time of my life
and that's the truth yeah that's the
truth
i never expected look i'm used to
teaching a classroom a seminar for
graduate students with eight or nine or
ten students or a uh or a regular
undergraduate class with 30 or an
occasional introductory course with a
few hundred i've done all of those
things many times
but
an audience you know
that i can count in the hundreds of
thousands on youtube and all of that no
that that's new
is there advice you can give given your
bold
and non-standard career and life advice
you can give to high school students
college students about how to have a
career like that or maybe how to have a
career or a life they can be proud of
first of all my advice is go for it the
conditions for doing that now are
infinitely better than they were when i
had to do it
and i could do it
and i can
i'm happy i did it becoming a teacher is
one of those decisions i made that i've
never regretted
um
and i've never regretted being a critic
of this society
never
i find it edifying i find it
i mean the gratitude people express to
me
for helping them see kind of what's
going on
is unbelievably encouraging i mean what
can i tell you so that fills you that
fills you with joy pointing out that the
emperor has no clothes it feels you
it's that's that's the life and not just
important isn't it because most of the
people
who say something like that to me are
people who
if they had the vocabulary and some of
them do
would say you know
i thought i was seeing through that
outfit that emperor was wearing yeah i
thought it and they did yeah and all
they needed was a little extra this
information or that factoid or this
logic ah
and they have that and i remember having
that too when i had a teacher who made
something clear that had been murky i
always felt gratitude and now i get that
gratitude a good bit and yes it is
enormously
gratifying and i i'm not sure i could
could get it any other way and it it
i had learned and i i'm walking
proof
that being a critic of society
and doing it systematically and sharing
it with other people
makes for a very good life
a very good life
speaking of which
however one one other aspect of human
nature is that life comes to an end
do you think about your death are you
afraid of it
afraid of it no think about it yes
yes
i'm not afraid
i've always thought you know death is
hard for the people that are left
when you're dead you know it's not gonna
bother you very much so it's i worry
more about my wife i'm very attached to
my wife
i am i mentioned to you i got married
when i was 23 years old that's my wife
to this day
um
so i'm lucky because that's
if you get married to anybody in age 23
it's either luck or it isn't
um
what has uh what role has this love
played in your life enormous
because i came from a family you know if
your family is
political refugees which mine were
who had to interrupt their lives
moved to another continent learn another
language find another life income and
job and it's the disruption
goes real deep
for any refugee so
so my mother and father were both
refugees
they met as refugees
um
so i had to in a way
make it up to them i had to be i was the
first child of their i have a younger
sister but the first child
and
you know there's a lot of psychological
pressure on you
if you're in that situation nobody means
you harm but
you've got to do
what they couldn't what was shut off to
them
in a way they want you to do it's the
closest they're going to get
to what they had hoped and my parents
were both university students my father
was a lawyer my mother had to leave the
university to run for her life
um
[Music]
so i had to perform you know i went to
high school
here in the united states i i had to get
all a's i had to be on the football team
i had to play the violin in the
orchestra i had to do all these because
everything had to be
achieved
so i'm an achievement crazy person that
way and but that's functional in this
dysfunctional society but on top of that
that's an achievement
within the game of this particular
society but then love seems to be a
thing that's greater
than that game is that something that
made you a better person oh god how is
it
how does that make you a better marxian
and a better everything because
my wife my wife by profession
is a psychotherapist
excellent i love it and i needed it yeah
and so i married it i didn't know what i
was doing at the time but i think as i
look back on it that was more
more than a little what was going on
and she has tutored me all my life about
a whole range of aspects of life
that my family never
talked about never dealt with
never
um at least explicitly
engaged in any of that because it was
all about survival the yes immigrant
challenges survival survives
and you're so busy
that you tell yourself you can't do that
you of course you can and there are
other reasons why you're not going to
look at those problems but the survival
is so urgent
that you can
fool yourself this way and my parents
uh did that
one last question
what's the meaning of life ritual
why i will quote you mr marx
let's go
life is struggle and uh for me
i have found
that to be true that the struggle
whether it is to build a relationship
with your child i have two children
uh whether it's to build one with your
spouse
whether it's to understand a complicated
argument
and simplify it so that you can
share the pleasure of understanding this
relationship
to a student or to an audience
these are
it's a struggle to do all those things
but that that network of struggles
that makes life
interesting intriguing
and satisfying
and meaningful and very meaningful and
that latter thing i gotta say you do
masterfully you're one of the great
communicators and educators
out there today and it's a huge honor
that you will sit with me for so many
hours thank you this is awesome
thanks for listening to this
conversation with richard wolff
to support this podcast please check out
our sponsors in the description
and now let me leave you with some words
from karl marx
the philosophers have only interpreted
the world in various ways
the point however
is to change it
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time